[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
OWEN SUSKIND: There is a boy
who was just like other boys
until one night, he
sees from his window
a storm on the horizon.
-Who are you?
-I'm Peter Pan.
And you're Captain Hook.
RON SUSKIND: All of a sudden, at
three years old, Owen vanishes.
The doctor says, let me
explain what autism is.
Some of the kids will
never talk again.
CORNELIA SUSKIND: I
remember thinking,
I'm just going to
hold you so tight
and love you so much
that whatever is going on
will go away.
RON SUSKIND: We were
beginning to give up hope.
And one day, we were watching
the Disney animated movies.
And he says he doesn't want to
grow up, like Mowgli or Peter
Pan.
CORNELIA SUSKIND: What
hell just happened?
RON SUSKIND: And all of a
sudden, it became clear to us.
He's using these movies to
make sense of the world.
He actually is
living in our world.
So at that point, we began to
speak to him in Disney dialog.
(IN VOICE OF IAGO) When did you
and I become such good friends?
Whatever works to get to Owen.
OWEN SUSKIND: I have been scared
my whole life of growing up.
Peter Pan doesn't want to grow
up because when you grow up,
you lose all your
magical childhood times.
CORNELIA SUSKIND: My hope is
that he is independent enough
to be able to grow
older on his own.
OWEN SUSKIND: When I
look in the mirror,
I see a proud autistic man
ready to meet a future that
is bright and full of wonder.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RON SUSKIND: He's going
to have to fall and fail.
We're not afraid of
that as we used to be.
CORNELIA SUSKIND: I just can't
believe how far Owen has come.
OWEN SUSKIND: The future,
I'm still searching for it.
CORNELIA SUSKIND: Who decides
what a meaningful life is?
SEBASTIAN: It's
like I always said.
-Children got to be free
to lead their own lives.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Well, that's a trailer.
But you have to watch
the entire movie, which
I did within three hours of
getting the link from Ron.
I was in London.
And for some reason,
Debbie reached out to me
and asked would I host this
particular talk of Authors
at Google.
I'm like, Ron Suskind?
Are you kidding me?
"Life, Animated"?
And I will tell you.
It's not only because Ron
is a Pulitzer-Prize-winning
journalist and has
written many books,
but it was specifically because
I remember exactly where I
was sitting, what office I
was in, when somehow, someone
sent me a link to a "New
York Times" story about you,
your wife, and your
son, and how Owen
discovered his voice through
relating to Disney characters.
And I immediately
shot it to my husband.
I said, oh, my god.
Someone else has had
the same experience.
My son Patrick is 23.
Has a condition called
Fragile X syndrome,
which has autistic-like
characteristics associated
with it.
And he, indeed, learned to
speak through Disney Pixar.
His modus is really "Toy Story."
RON SUSKIND: It's
a great choice.
It's a great movie.
There's a ton there to work
with, tons to work with.
SPEAKER: So Ron, we could talk
a lot about your credentials.
But what was striking to
me in my first conversation
with you was the excitement
and the belief and the purpose
that your life has.
Probably you always had it.
You're a serious journalist.
But there's something
magical that's
happened through
telling Owen's story.
RON SUSKIND: Yeah.
SPEAKER: And you could
see in your bio--
one could you say you've
had a 20-plus year struggle.
I would say "journey,"
a hero's journey,
of raising a child like Owen.
So can we talk a little
bit about that segment
we saw where Owen, little curly
haired boy, loses his voice.
What's it feel like?
And looking back now, tell
us about that journey.
And I know we're
going to intersperse
our discussion with clips
from the documentary.
So we'll have moments
to illustrate points.
RON SUSKIND: Yeah,
it's interesting
because folks know
the other books.
This is my sixth book.
And the other books--
I wrote a book
called "A Hope in the Unseen,"
a New York City African-American
kid who goes to the
Ivy League, and then
for books on presidents and
power, where I was investigated
and things like that, big,
noisy books about America
and America's role in the world.
And what's interesting
is this story
was the story behind
all of those stories.
It wasn't like we
were hiding it.
But we became clear as we grew,
Cornelia and I, that Owen was
really driving us, as Owen
would say in his parlance,
that we were sidekicks trying
to find our inner heroes.
SPEAKER: Now, can you
describe for this audience,
who might not be Disney
aficionados, what
a sidekick is?
RON SUSKIND: OK, so I'll
just jump a little bit ahead.
But it's a big architecture
that Owen has created
in his head over many years.
Owen is thrown out of a school
when he's about 11 years old.
Now, already he had memorized 50
Disney animated movies as sound
alone.
And we were talking
in Disney dialogue.
That's how we communicated.
That's the only way
we could communicate.
But he gets to a point where he
doesn't have a lot of speech.
Enough, but he's whacked.
I mean, he begins to see what
the world sees of him when
he's thrown out of this school
he loves and deemed uneducable.
And he goes in the basement.
And he begins to draw
with peculiar intensity.
He's grabbing books and pads.
We don't know what he's doing.
It's like he's
working on a project.
And I go down to the basement
a few months into this period--
and we know he's busted up.
And he's really broken.
But he can tell us how he feels,
which is terrible for a parent.
And I grab a book.
And I open it up.
And I see there are
hundreds pictures, precise,
just like a Disney animator
would draw, all sidekicks,
no heroes.
Sebastian, when Ariel
loses her voice, that
look of fear-- how do you know?
[GASPS]
There's 10 of those.
SPEAKER: Nice West Indian voice.
RON SUSKIND: That's right, yeah.
I mean, we do voices
in our family.
It's the way we
talk to each other.
And 100 sidekicks, no heroes.
Of course, he saw that
the world had judged him.
As he told us later,
he's not a hero.
He's a sidekick.
Now, we ask Owen later, he says,
well, a sidekick's important.
They help the hero
fulfill their destiny.
Without them, nothing happens.
And I'm a sidekick.
SPEAKER: Does that
make you the hero?
RON SUSKIND: Well, it's
hard to know because he's
grown into the hero.
But at the end of the
book, he writes two things.
One is, "I am the protector
of the sidekicks."
SPEAKER: Love that.
RON SUSKIND: And the last thing
he writes, "Np sidekick gets
left behind."
In a way, this is
his answer back
to what the world sees of him.
You know, I was already
out as a journalist
writing about the
left-behind people
of the world in
inner city America,
in Afghanistan,
in Pakistan, folks
who were in the discard pile.
Of course, the most
left behind person
I knew was living
in the bedroom.
And more and more over
the years, as Walter
says-- Owen's older brother--
Owen is our best teacher.
Silent child for many years,
making sense of the world
from what he can grab from
the wide world of content,
the web, an image,
and turning it
into a vessel that becomes a
vessel that we all can board.
And that's we have now with
the movie, that everyone
is boarding this ocean liner
of making sense of the world
through passion, through
the things we love,
through things that are often
not validated as important.
But they are.
It's what we do with them.
It's how we own them, how
we fit them to our lives.
And that's why we're having
so much fun with this movie.
I mean, it's amazing.
So we won the Director's
Award at Sundance.
That's where it
debut in January.
And this was the first
time we saw it with people.
And Owen is there.
And Cornelia and Walter
saw it for the first time
at Sundance, which is audacious.
Obviously, you can see I'm
married to an audacious woman
here, ferocious.
And she's like, well,
we know our life.
The question is will
people get our life?
And we'll know it at
Sundance with 1,000 people.
At the end of the movie,
the lights come up.
And Roger Ross Williams, an
amazing director, Academy Award
winner, says, ladies and
gentlemen, Owen Suskind.
SPEAKER: [GASPS]
RON SUSKIND: Owen bounds
down onto the stage.
And everyone is up.
And I've never heard
cheers like this.
I mean, they just cheered
themselves hoarse.
And Owen's just feeling
this wash over him.
I mean, the whole thing
started with the book and then
the movie six years ago,
where Owen said to me--
and Cornelia's like--
he's like, people
don't see me for who I am.
SPEAKER: He's the hero though.
RON SUSKIND: Well,
that's what's emerged.
But he has a
different twist on it.
He says, really, really,
we're all really sidekicks,
at our best when we help
others fulfill their destiny.
And on that day, we
find our inner heroes.
But we're really
sidekicks deep down.
And you don't get
redrawn in this life.
I love that because it means
that these notions of heroism
that are often very
brittle are now
recast by a left
behind person to say,
heroism is a choice of what you
do to help someone else fulfill
their destiny.
And in that way, you
fulfill your own.
That's a beautiful
recasting that, of course,
someone with autism does
because that's their gift.
And so much of
what we see here is
a display of what I
call compensatory gifts.
And all I have all
these neuroscientists.
I'm living in neuroscience
fantasy camp these days.
I can call them on the phone.
SPEAKER: Tom Insel
is right here.
RON SUSKIND: We got the
great Tom Insel here,
who is like a rock star.
SPEAKER: And a Googler.
RON SUSKIND: And a Googler.
So, tom, just so you know--
he's sitting near me here.
Tom was the head of
the National Center
for Mental Health since 2002.
Right?
And Tom was already a
big autism researcher.
But then he sat in really
the hot seat of an era
when, at Tom's behest, we began
to redefine neurodivergence
as maybe not all the big P
pathology we thought it was,
to say, look, yes, the
deficits and the disabilities
are profound, but
it's more complicated.
And what my neuroscience
friends tell
me is that for every
deficit that is visible--
and we measure them religiously,
exhaustively-- somewhere,
there's an equal and
opposite strength.
The question is
not if, but where.
The brain, neuroplasticity,
its definition,
a working definition is
that the brain finds a way,
with often enormous ingenuity.
And that neural
pathway's a strength.
Now, Owen is bursting with
compensatory strengths
in this movie.
And it's not something
we knew for a long time.
For a long time,
we said, oh, my.
What's going to happen?
What will his life be like?
And so that's our journey.
SPEAKER: Can you tell us the
moment that you recognized
this compensatory strength?
Was it that first phrase
he uttered in the movie
that Cornelia responded to?
I mean, he comes out with
profound heroic statements
about the nature of humanity.
in this movie.
RON SUSKIND: Well, look,
we've got a couple clips.
Let's do a clip.
So let's do the clip-- right
now, you can see it happening,
where you see Owen
as a little guy.
He's 2 1/2.
He's got a few hundred
word vocabulary,
like a typical 2 1.2 year old.
We're living in what we called
then the continent of normal,
whatever that means.
We didn't even know we lived
there until later, until we
were exiled from there.
OK, so we're living in this
lovely house in Dedham.
And you can see the clip.
And then I'll tell
you what happens.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Oh, no!
[OWEN SHOUTS]
CORNELIA SUSKIND:
Daddy and Owen fighting
with swords in the leaves.
RON SUSKIND: Owen, who are you?
-I'm Peter Pan.
And you're Captain Hook.
-Oh, I'm Captain Hook.
You're Peter Pan.
OK, come on, Pan.
You're a demon.
Yes!
RON SUSKIND: There's a
video we came across.
And then once we found it,
we couldn't stop watching it.
OWEN SUSKIND: Your weapon.
-Thank you, thank you.
That's very chivalrous of you.
Now, in a way, it's just
an unremarkable video
of a dad and the son playing.
I'm chasing Owen around.
He's chasing me around.
He's Peter Pan.
I'm Captain Hook.
Oh, no!
[OWEN SHOUTS]
RON SUSKIND: At the time we
shot it, I'm in my early 30s.
I'm a reporter for "The
Wall Street Journal."
And our life is taking shape
just the way we'd want it.
-We had two beautiful boys.
We'd just had our second boy.
We had a little tiny house.
But it was just like
our dream house.
-You want to say hi to Mommy?
-Hi Mommy!
CORNELIA SUSKIND: Hi guys.
Everything was
falling into place.
RON SUSKIND: But all of a
sudden, at three years old,
Owen vanishes.
CORNELIA SUSKIND:
Goodbye, Peter Pan.
RON SUSKIND: So that's
the before time.
We moved to Washington about
a week after that was shot.
Exciting time.
I became the senior
national affairs
writer for "The Wall
Street Journal,"
a job you got to kill people
to get I killed 10 guys to get
the job, nice family
men, good guys.
[LAUGHTER]
And we're just in a
hub-bub, boxes to unpack,
new school for Walt,
new job for Dad.
And a couple weeks in, about
a month, Cornelia's like,
something's wrong with Owen.
He's unhappy.
He was always a happy guy.
And he's-- then he's
not looking at me.
I mean, I stopped
telling her what
was happening at work
because every day,
she had another story.
And he's losing speech.
About three months in, that
few hundred word vocabulary
is down to a single
word, juice, one word.
And we don't know
what's happening.
It doesn't make sense.
Kids don't grow backwards.
Maybe he banged his head when
we weren't looking or ingested
something toxic, god forbid.
So we see a doctor.
She says, you need to see a
different doctor, a specialist.
And we see her.
And she says autism.
What did we know?
We knew "Rain Man."
1988, that's what
most people knew.
This was 1994,
first months of '94.
I said, you're telling
me my son is like Dustin
Hoffman in that movie?
She's like, well,
maybe, a lot of them
don't speak again though.
He might not talk anymore.
Yeah, we didn't hear anything
else in the visit after that.
All we heard was
noise in our ears.
Cornelia and I literally
lifted out of our bodies.
We were floating
on the drop ceiling
just like this looking
down on the scene,
the kid on the rug looking
at his hands, the doctor,
and these two parents.
I mean, we used to say
we left them in there.
They didn't leave with
us, those parents.
I used to miss them.
But we don't anymore because we
were starting a journey where
we were-- Owen changed,
but we were changing,
which we didn't realize.
So off we went into a
time of silence and panic.
We found a new doctor,
which was good.
And the first
thing he says to me
is, what do you do for a living.
I'm like, me?
I'm a reporter.
He's like, I'm so
sorry to hear that.
I'm like, why?
So you're good with numbers?
I'm like, [INAUDIBLE] math.
I test OK.
Investment banking, a
terrific career choice.
I'm like, what do mean?
He said, you just paid
me $120 for this visit.
You're going to need to
see me three times a week.
It's not covered.
SPEAKER: Wow.
RON SUSKIND: Oh, god.
I said, this is what I do.
I'm a story guy.
I'm a reporter.
He said, you'd better
be really good at it.
We we're bankrupt by the summer.
And then we were
just living in fear.
Now, Owen is silent at
this point, no words.
But he's murmuring-- a few
months in-- a little jibberish.
He's saying,
juicerfuzz, juicerfuzz.
We're like, sounds
are good, like a baby.
And Cornelia thought
he wanted more juice.
But he didn't want the juice.
He knocked over the sippy cup.
He had graduated
to the big boy cup.
But the motor function
goes crazy with autism.
The one area it worked
though, the motor function,
was his thumb on the remote--
SPEAKER: Sure.
RON SUSKIND: The thumb
on the rewind button.
His brother taught him
how to use the rewind.
And he watched "The
Little Mermaid" a lot.
Now, how many people here have
seen "The Little Mermaid"?
every single person.
SPEAKER: What was
his favorite scene?
Because I'm sure he had one.
RON SUSKIND: Well, he had one.
You know this with Patrick.
So the scene he
loved was where Ariel
loses her voice, where she makes
her deal with Ursula the sea
witch.
OK?
So, you know Ariel, a selfish
girl, wants what she wants,
do anything to get it.
She's working now
at Goldman Sachs.
She's doing fine.
[LAUGHTER]
The whole Eric thing
didn't work out.
The prince, the whole prince
thing doesn't usually work.
And so she'll make her
deal with the sea witch.
And of course, the
sea witch says,
it won't cost you much, a
trifle really, just your voice.
Owen rewinds it.
Walter's like, Owen,
just watch the movie.
Second rewind, third rewind.
Cornelia grabs me!
It's not "juice."
I said, it's not "juice."
It's "just."
I grab Owen.
"Just your voice!"
And he looks at me for
the first time in a year.
And he says, "juicerfuzz,
juicerfuzz, juicerfuzz."
Walter starts
jumping on the bed.
Owen's talking again.
And Cornelia starts to cry
and says, he's still in there.
This goes on for years.
We see our doctor the next day,
Alan Rosenblatt, terrific guy.
He says, look, sit down.
You're not going
to like this word.
This is called echolalia.
I'm like, oh, I hate that word.
Is that what-- yeah, it's
kind of what it sounds like.
Like a parrot?
He's like yeah, they're
just repeating the sounds.
The thinking is they
don't understand them.
I mean, we called this
our Helen Keller moment.
So that's where we lived for
years, between the pet store
and Helen Keller.
And he's murmuring
more jibberish,
scripting we call it, taking
little pieces of dialogue.
The view then is not only
is the Disney obsessive,
but it's not productive
for him to be doing that.
Jump ahead to the
next scene actually,
where-- so you met
me and Cornelia,
this extraordinary woman, who
is also journalist like me.
But as soon as
Owen is diagnosed,
she's like, I have
my job forever, him.
And your job is to make
more money than any reporter
in the history of newspapers.
SPEAKER: Why don't
you write a book?
RON SUSKIND: Outta
here, get outta here!
Enjoy, have fun.
Right, I mean, thank god I won a
Pulitzer Prize soon thereafter.
But necessity is the mother
of terrific invention.
Trust me.
So Owen and Cornelia and
I are at the core of it.
But there's another
key actor here,
which is Walter,
who is as important
a character in this
movie as anybody
in the book and our life.
Now, he's the sibling.
And he's like a lot of siblings
of people with disabilities.
From early on, he sees
Mom and Dad are really
overwhelmed here.
So I'm good.
I'm on my own.
It's like a little
character out of Dickens.
See ya.
OK?
David Copperfield.
So Walt is tough and resilient
and can handle anything
the world throws at him.
This is the story Cornelia and
I tell each other about Walt
because I'm a
story guy, and this
is a lot about story, the
stories we tell ourselves
to make our way in the world.
Owen does it too.
So the story about Walt was
that, the Jewish marine,
handle anything the
world throws at him.
But he'll never leave his little
brother behind, two-part story.
We don't even notice he
gets emotional on only one
day of the year, his birthday.
It doesn't fit our story.
So on Walter's ninth
birthday, Owen's almost seven,
Walt's in the backyard
with the other kids.
The kids leave.
Owen's back there.
Walt gets a little weepy.
Owen follows us back
into the kitchen.
Now at this point,
after years of therapy--
I mean, morning, noon,
and night-- Owen's
up to a three-word
sentence, I want juice.
And we're feeling OK about that.
At least he can
say what he wants.
He follows us into the kitchen.
He looks at Cornelia.
He looks at me.
Something odd,
something's bubbling up.
And he goes, Walter
doesn't want to grow up,
like Mowgli or Peter Pan.
And off he goes.
We're like, what's that?
It's like a thunderbolt
went through the kitchen.
So we're struck silent.
And then we can stop
talking for hours.
Finally, Cornelia says to me,
look, you're the crazy one.
You wear the propeller hats
at the birthday parties.
Find a way in.
I'm tired.
I'm up every night with him.
This is your job.
The guys don't
often get a prompter
they can try to lift the
back of the Volkswagen.
That's mostly the mom.
So I go up.
And it's this very
night that this occurs.
So let's play that second scene.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RON SUSKIND: So I
go up to his room.
I see Owen on the bed,
flipping through a Disney book.
And over to my left, I
see Iago, the puppet.
Now Iago is the evil
sidekick to the villain Jafar
from "Aladdin."
Now, I know Owen
loves this puppet.
-Jafar!
Jafar!
Get a grip!
[CHOKES]
-I grab the puppet.
I pull it up to my elbow.
And I begin to crawl across
the rug as quietly as I can.
And Owen turns to
the puppet like he's
bumping into an old friend.
I say to him,
[IAGO VOICE] Owen, Owen,
how does it feel to be you?
-And I said not good because
I don't have any friends.
-Now I'm under the bedspread.
And I just bite down hard.
I just say to myself,
stay in character.
[IAGO VOICE] And I said,
OK, OK, Owen, when did you
and I become such good friends?
And he said, when I watched
"Aladdin," you made me laugh.
And then we talk, Owen
and Iago, for a minute,
minute-and-a-half.
It's the first conversation
we've ever had.
[END PLAYBACK]
RON SUSKIND: So what happens
after the two minutes,
after we have this
moment, all of a sudden,
Owen clears his throat.
[CLEARS THROAT]
And he says, [JAFAR VOICE]
"I love the way
your foul little mind works."
That's Jafar.
It's the next line.
And I threw off the
bed-- I was like, ah,
we're talking in Disney dialog.
oh, my god.
This is the way
we'll communicate.
The next night, we start what
we called the basement sessions.
"Jungle Book" was big.
Owen loves "Jungle Book."
So we had all four of
us go to the basement.
Now, I'm going to be
Baloo, which kind of works
other than the height thing.
Cornelia is Bagheera,
the protective panther.
Walter's King Louie.
"Tell me the secret of
man's red fire, man cub."
And Owen's Mowgli.
And off we go,
scene after scene.
Now, we need the
screen because Owen's
going to outrun you quick.
He's memorized 50
movies, all of them.
He can go for hours.
So we do a scene.
We refresh.
We do it.
So by about the
seventh scene in,
it's a scene where
Baloo says to Mowgli,
he says, you know, you'd
make one great bear.
And Mowgli says, do you
think so, Papa bear?
And then Owen hugs me.
And I'm not sure if it's Mowgli
and Baloo or me and Owen.
And of course, Cornelia
says it doesn't matter.
And it doesn't.
And that's what happens.
We move forward for years
playing animated characters.
That's how Owen gets his
speech back over years.
He learns to read
by reading credits,
all tapping
intrinsic motivation.
This is part of autism.
They're self-directed
just like poets are.
This is what I do.
This is who I am.
They won't do the transaction
in a one-size-fits-all.
They'll never do it.
And they'll never
succeed doing it.
So we start living a double
life, the whole family.
By day, Walt's going to school,
riding his bike in blizzards
cause he doesn't want Cornelia
to drop him off and have
Owen come in because then
it'll be about his brother.
What's with the brother?
Cornelia's running ragged.
I'm interviewing presidents,
[BILL CLINTON VOICE]
some of who I know are
not telling me the truth.
I mean--
[LAUGHTER]
I'm not sure, but--
And at night, we're
animated characters, in
the basement meditating
on the emergence of the hero.
SPEAKER: Were you conscious
that you were meditating
on the emergence of the hero?
Or did that come over time?
RON SUSKIND: Owen made
us conscious of it
because, as Patrick does,
as so many of the folks do,
he was starting to use
the narrative frames
and tropes as structures
to understand himself.
And so in a way, Owen, through
these years, starts to lead,
like saying, no,
no, this character
has not fulfilled his destiny.
And this character
here is confused.
But here's the twist.
This character
advances the plot.
He was looking for
people who were advancing
the plot in his own
life to match the mirror
and codebreaker that
the content provided.
Again, we didn't know
really what we were seeing.
Now we know.
Now, all of our
neuroscience friends
and the therapists
and the [INAUDIBLE]
are saying, yeah,
yeah, this is the way
it actually is
working and works.
The content they
embrace is a choice
which shows the way their brains
actually work, what feeds them.
The map kids might be
different from the Disney kids.
But they all do it the same way.
They use it as their mirror,
their map, their guide,
their vessel.
Now, for us neurotypicals,
we're like, gosh,
if I have to watch
"Dumbo" one more time,
I'm going to run
away with the circus.
But then you're like, no,
no-- Cornelia said it best.
Loving what he loves is the
way we are going to love him.
And we'll do it all together.
And we're going to live
in this underground cavern
that he's building.
It's like an underground palace.
So another clip is
Owen going forward.
And you're going
to see that as he
gets through his teenage years,
he moves out into the world.
Goes to a school on Cape
Cod called Riverview.
And it's a big jump for him.
He's leaving home.
And he starts Disney Club.
We know other kids
are doing this.
But we don't really know
it in terms of something
we can touch.
So here is Disney Club.
This is very cool.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Oh, OK.
Listen up.
As soon as everyone
gets here, we can begin.
-Hey, Owen?
-Yeah.
-Could I just recommend that
instead of saying listen up,
you say may I have
your attention?
-May I have your
attention, please?
When everyone gets
here, we'll begin.
I started a Disney Club So I
can get to know more people
and they can be around me,
so I can be more popular.
It worked.
Tonight, we're watching
some of "The Lion
King," because this year
is the big 20th anniversary
of the original release
of "The Lion King."
-Yeah, sure!
-Shall we?
-Then-- then not only
am big Disney fanatic,
but I also like to play magical
movie scores on this piano.
-Yeah!
[APPLAUSE]
[PIANO MUSIC, PEOPLE SINGING]
OWEN SUSKIND: We watch parts
of the Disney animated films
and discuss them and
see what they're really
about in our lives.
[END PLAYBACK]
RON SUSKIND: The first
Disney Club we went to-- Owen
goes to school in Cape Cod.
We were living in Washington.
I was fighting it
out in that terrain.
And I came up to Harvard to
be the writer in residence.
So we're only an hour away.
And it was better we
were close to Owen.
It's far, Washington
to Cape Cod.
And we were just an
hour down the road.
And Owen starts at this school.
And he starts Disney Club.
We;re like, fabulous.
This is great.
He'd never even been in a club.
Now, he's the
president of a club.
And so we're like, so
what do you do every week?
Well, we watch Disney
movies and eat popcorn.
I'm like, OK, you
need to do something.
You need a program.
So about eight months in, after
Cornelia and I are hawking him
every week, he's
like, well, they said
we can have parent advisers.
So I guess you guys can come.
So we're like,
[IMITATES SCREECHING TIRES].
We make it from Harvard Square
to the Cape in 32 minutes.
And we get into the room.
And there's 12
kids just like him.
That's the revelation.
And they're watching
"Dumbo" first time
we-- which is a
great choice really.
I mean, it's one of the
quintessential narratives.
And if Joseph Campbell
was sitting here
with this, or Maria
Tatar from Harvard,
the folklore chief who is
my buddy, she'd say, yeah,
"Dumbo" is a story humanity
has been telling itself
for thousands of years
in every culture,
just like "Beauty and the
Beast" and "Snow White."
The Brothers Grimm took them.
Disney took them.
They're the tales that
help us manage our life.
They're not simple.
They're quite
complicated, in fact,
in terms of all the human
attributes that are challenged
and then express themselves.
So I say to this young lady
sitting there-- I'm like,
"Dumbo."
She's like, that's
my number one.
OK, so you tell me why.
She's like, OK, well, well, I
didn't talk for a long time.
And Dumbo doesn't talk.
What we find out later is
many of the non-verbal kids
are bonding with non-verbal
characters, of course,
of course.
They express all
emotions without words.
She said, but then
I learned to talk.
And I was an outcast for much
of my life, junior high school.
And then I saw
what it was about.
You see, the things that made
Dumbo an outcast, those ears,
he learns that they're
his greatest strength
and allow him to soar.
And that's the
way it is with me.
The things that
make me different
are my greatest strengths.
And I can soar too.
That's why I'm a Dumbo girl.
That's all we needed to hear.
That's Emily, his girlfriend.
It's like, that's good.
That's the one for me.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, [INAUDIBLE].
Are you getting more than that
with 10 dates of small talk?
I mean, really?
No, you know that's no.
So they become a couple.
By the time he's
doing this third year,
when he's the
president for three--
there's like eight boy-girl
couples in Disney Club.
They're speaking a
language they share.
It's a lingua franca
of their affinity,
their interest, a language,
just like the languages we talk.
And so what's really
powerful about this
is what it helps us
see with new eyes,
I guess Proust would
say, as to the way people
find each other in
a way they can now
and they kind of couldn't
when I'm a kid, based
on their powerful
interests that define them
and that they can
go 100 feet deep on.
We were talking a minute ago
with one of the young ladies
here about-- your
brother, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
RON SUSKIND: And
what is he, Disney?
Or what's his thing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, he loves Disney.
RON SUSKIND: Does he?
So one of the things
I thought about
is in a little
technological changes,
some things have
an enormous effect.
And one that all
of you, I think,
probably know is when the VCR
arrives for home use in home
penetration around the
mid-'80's, that's actually huge
because content then was
on free feed, on demand.
And everyone built-up
those little libraries.
Remember the little clamshell
box with the VCR's, VHS tapes.
And that was really
important for Owen.
And I dare say that
before that, there
were probably more
kids who were map kids
and train schedule kids.
And more of them
migrated over to videos
because they were getting
more from them as models,
as mirrors, as really clues
that they could really decipher.
And that's kind of big
because what's happening now
is that Disney clubs-- every
kid who left that room went out
into the world after they
graduated and started
a Disney club, which is neat.
So now virtually, they
can meet other people.
And they can share the
thing that defines them.
That's a very exciting change.
And the other
change is that when
people hear Owen
and the other kids
in that room talk about what
they see in a movie all of us
have seen, they're like, how
can they see so much more
in the movie than I do?
And I test really well.
What's going on here?
That's good.
That up ends lots of things that
end with a lot of people being
dismissive of those who don't
fit one-size-fits-all models
of measuring ability or
value or in a way, meaning.
There's a line in the
middle of the movie that
jumps off the screen.
And every time I hear
this-- and Cornelia says it.
I cry every single time where
she says, at one point--
and it's because someone
challenged us, and an expert,
in fact.
And we could see the
way she looked at Owen.
And it wasn't the
way we saw him.
It was a little bit
like the broken toy.
And she said, you know, Ron
once said to me-- she says,
forty feet tall on the screen.
She said, who decides what
the meaningful life is?
Who makes that call?
And the idea of the who is
a challenge that you may not
be making that decision
in ways you think.
Maybe the culture, maybe
certain ideas of success,
maybe the tyranny of the
oo-ahs, oo, Harvard, ah,
Cape Cod Community College.
Huh.
And why shouldn't we
talking about the one
son and not the other.
All that shapes us.
And I think it shapes
us often unconsciously.
Owen called that
question in our family.
And that made us better,
really measurably better.
When I say he helped us
find our inner heroes,
that's how he did it,
by forcing the question.
So that question, and
what I consider progress,
was discussed last
week at Dartmouth,
where they saw the movie.
And university-wide, they
did discussion groups
asking that question.
Who decides the meaningful life?
Are you deciding?
Someone deciding that for you?
You didn't realize
that they are.
I love that conversation.
And in three weeks, the entire
Houston public school system,
all of them, all the staff,
29,000 people and all 200,000
students, are going to watch
the movie and ask that question.
Now, mind you, many of them
are African-American or
Latino-American students
from tough circumstances.
And the prompt
will be, you decide
what the meaningful life is.
Don't let anyone
impose that on you.
That's your choice.
And the last thing
I'll say about this
is about three months ago,
we had an amazing moment,
where we watched the movie.
They screened it at Disney.
Yeah, I know.
It was crazy.
It was like a gigantic
catharsis in a theater.
SPEAKER: I think they
should employ him.
Come on.
RON SUSKIND: OK.
Is this being telecast?
I'm calling Burbank, California.
No, I mean, Disney has been
great to Owen, in fact.
And he knows lots
of people at Disney.
And they love him.
And he loves them.
Of course, he knows
every credit they
ev-- he's like a walking IMDb,
which they love, of course.
No one know that.
Really?
My wife doesn't know that.
SPEAKER: Owen knows it.
RON SUSKIND: Owen does.
So they screen the movie.
And one of the animators,
they're all bawling their eyes
out and they're cheering.
And one of them said,
Owen, what about that
question that your mom asked
about the meaningful life.
Who decides the meaningful life?
And the room got very quiet.
It's a challenge, in a way.
And Owen just there
about 30 seconds.
And he said, I do.
I decide.
Boy, that feels
like justice to me.
So that's what's happening.
SPEAKER: Well, Ron, I
could ask 1,000 questions.
I think we have another
video clip to show.
RON SUSKIND: Yeah, and we have
20 minutes still for questions.
And this little video.
So we're OK.
SPEAKER: We're good.
We're good because I don't
even need to be here.
We'll just wind him up.
[LAUGHTER]
RON SUSKIND: No, Eileen.
Without you, what would I do?
SPEAKER: But here
are some things
that have occurred to me.
RON SUSKIND: She's my sidekick.
SPEAKER: I'm the sidekick.
I'm not used to
being the sidekick.
RON SUSKIND: And
she [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: But there is something
in this journey as a parent.
And at a point in your life,
I'm sure you had sorry eyes.
Your sister, your cousin,
oh, I'm so sorry for you.
What people don't
recognize is the enrichment
that comes with having
non-conventional situations
in your life and the
strength that comes
with finding other pathways in.
It sounds to me though,
you just had an intuitive
moment there with Iago, caw,
and followed it quite naturally.
A lot of the techniques that
are introduced to parents
is get into their passion area.
My child, it was subways,
horses, and Disney.
Those were the three paths in.
And as a reward for his
first use of the big boy
toilet, my son-- I was
bundled in the cold going
home one night from work.
And I see my husband and
son leaving the apartment.
And I shout across the
windy streets of New York,
where are you guys going?
Patrick pooped in the potty!
We're going to the subway.
RON SUSKIND: Oh, my god.
[LAUGHTER] That's amazing.
It's amazing.
SPEAKER: Guess where he
wanted to go the next day?
The subway.
I'm like, no, no, no,
it's not every time.
[LAUGHTER]
So we've got no over
that particular instance.
But you just knew that you had
to reward or follow a passion.
One of the first conversations
I had with Patrick
was while he was
speaking to a horse.
He'd gone away to
school in Boston.
He came back.
And we were near
a horse breeding
farm, where there was this one
horse, Traveler, whom he loved.
And we walked up
with our carrots.
And he started speaking
in full clear sentences.
Oh, Traveler, my
buddy, my friend, I've
missed you so much.
How have you been?
You're getting bigger, bud.
A whole conversation.
I'm like, what about me?
You want to ask
me how I'm doing?
RON SUSKIND: You need to
start whinnying is what
you need, stamping your foot.
SPEAKER: But we absolutely
indulged those passions.
And so I mean, some of us
might be parents, siblings,
interested parties.
We may be
neurotypically atypical
ourselves in this room.
What can you tell
us about raising
a child with extra
needs and accessing
these passions as paths in and
enrichment for your own life.
RON SUSKIND: I love
your horse story.
And the subways, of course.
I mean, in a way, Patrick
not ingesting context
of the supposed to's.
So he sees things as they are.
Look, I mean, we think subways--
oh, what's the big deal?
Subways are amazing.
SPEAKER: They are amazing.
RON SUSKIND: I mean,
think about it,
a train that runs underground
jammed with people.
I mean, that's an
amazing creation.
And we are taught
as little kids,
horses can't understand
what you're saying.
But they kind of do.
Patrick doesn't "know
better," so he tries things
that we're taught not to do.
And I think that's
a big part of this
is you've got to look at
yourself as not necessarily
superior, which is hard to do
sometimes, to the individual.
You say, they are my peer.
I'm just different.
That's all.
So part of that is looking at
the neurotypical differences
you have to them.
And that's sometimes hard to
look at yourself that way.
But that's the key, actually,
because then, you'll
burn off a lot of
neurotypical blind spots
that you either have or
are taught to embrace.
I mean, I'll give an example.
A famous molecular biologist,
I won't say what his name is.
A great guy, he's
friend of mine.
He called me up when he had
read the book two years ago.
And he says, gosh, I
wish my kid-- Paul,
let's say-- was a Disney kid.
I wish he was a Disney kid.
He's a map kid.
And I'm like, OK.
So we're on the phone.
And I'm like, so the question
is, are all of these affinities
created equal?
And all of a sudden, we start
to think, wait a second.
Maps are the two-dimensional
rendering of all humanity.
The cartographers of the
great geniuses of their age.
Everything's on a map if
you know where to look.
I said to my friend,
you need to start
speaking map with your kid.
A month later, they've been
speaking map for a month.
He calls me up.
He's like, an amazing
thing happened.
And he talks to me about
how the kid expressed love
by identifying a city on a
map there that represented,
in its characteristics,
his father.
A girl comes up to meet
at the Semel Institute
not too long ago.
I gave a speech
over there at UCLA.
A perfect example,
a dinosaur girl.
I'm like dinosaurs, great.
So teach me.
That's the way you do it.
You are an expert.
I'm not.
Teach me.
OK?
And she's like, OK.
I said, what's your favorite?
She was like, I don't
want to tell you.
You'll laugh at me.
I said, I promise I won't laugh.
OK, the velociraptor.
I'm like, OK, that's
a vicious animal.
So why the Raptor?
OK, well, the Raptor,
it's a pack animal.
And all pack animals
are not all the same.
They move together.
They need to recognize
what each does well.
And if they work together,
they can take down
much larger dinosaurs.
So it's about interdependency
and about relying on each other
and seeing each other
as we are really.
And that's why I
love the raptor.
I mean, there's not
a paleontologist
in the world that would
come up with that.
What I love about that if she's
drawing from the affinity what
she needs to know herself.
That's the reversal
of the telescope.
That's what's happening.
And that's why when you
feed these affinities,
these individuals grow into
these mighty individuals.
They're square pegs.
If you shave off the edges
to fit them into a world
that only prizes
round holes, you're
going to cut off the best stuff.
So the key is, how do you have
them identify their passion--
and most parents
know early-- feed it,
and let them turn
it into a pathway
because it's not a prison.
OK, we got this video.
You've got to see this.
This is us doing it.
So Tom knows about this.
When the book came
out two years ago,
I spoke to the UN General
Assembly and Congress and NIH.
And we got an
avalanche of parents
from all over the
world saying, I get it.
I see now my kid
for who they are.
But how do I do this?
I work out of the house.
So does my wife.
And we can't sit in the
basement watching Disney movies
for the next 10 years.
So help us.
So what we did is we
grabbed neuroscientists
and technologists from
all over the country,
pulled them together in
a kind of consortium,
to build what we kind
of knew we needed.
And it's a platform.
It's a new kind of
communications platform.
It's called Sidekicks.
Owen named it, number one.
And actually, Owen
is on the patent
for guided personal
companion that was approved
by the US patent office.
Isn't that great?
Because he helped us
come up with the idea.
So here it is.
So this is a four-minute video.
Just hold it for one second.
Let me explain what happens.
What happens is the
kids download an avatar
on their phone.
They get to pick
which one they want.
When you talk into your phone
or type, or into your computer,
it comes through in real time
in the voice of the character,
wherever they are.
You could be in Mumbai doing it.
They talk right back to it.
It's all automated
speech recognition.
Natural [INAUDIBLE].
And so it picks up their speech.
And you're having a mediated
conversation that breathes life
into the entity.
The entity mirrors
their interests.
It loves what they love
because what we have is
we have thousands of clips
from Disney and Warner
Brothers and all the
big content providers.
These kids love what everyone
loves-- Harry Potter, Star
Wars, Disney-- that stream
across the platform.
That's the stuff of
their language after all.
The video runs.
And the sidekick then--
you behind the curtain,
the therapist, the parent,
a brother or sister--
speaks to them
about what they see.
The big matching game--
I know what Ariel feels,
but what do you feel?
And what does this tell you?
How can you apply
that to your life?
What does it tell
you about yourself?
Code breaking with human
essence assistance.
They neat part-- and a lot of
you guys, you're a lot of AI
people here-- is that
because the dialogue
is context aware-- they
know who the person is.
It's not one to many.
It's one to one-- and domain
limited, because that's autism,
and not only the subjects
that are domain limited,
but it's an individual,
it grows into automation
with significant speed.
So the person is needed behind
the curtain less and less
and then only when
needed, they're summoned.
So these are the first three
kids, all spectrum kids,
to use the device last year at
a thing we did at a university
usability study.
Now, we knew all
their affinities.
I think the girl
is a "Frozen" girl.
The boy is a "Toy Story"
boy, the little guy.
And the other guy's
a Star Wars guy.
Each of them showed
a higher level
of expressive and receptive
speech and connection
than basically the parents had
ever seen on the first usage.
It's crazy.
OK, so watch this video.
It's very cool.
SPEAKER: Crazy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AUTOMATED VOICE: Hey, there.
I'm Jaze, your new sidekick.
Nice to meet you.
-Hey.
AUTOMATED VOICE: I heard you
really like Disney movies.
Is that right?
-Yes.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Want
to watch a funny video?
-Yeah, I do.
-I don't have a skull or bones.
-[LAUGHS]
-She's laughing at it.
-That was really funny.
-This is a very useful
tool for a family like ours
because we are currently stuck.
So we know what his deficit is.
But we don't know
how to help him.
-A lot of the hard
work that's been
done with him in
the last seven years
around emotions
and other people's
emotions and his
emotions and how they all
interact, if I had had this
device seven years ago,
he would be a lot further
along than where he his now.
AUTOMATED VOICE: I like burgers.
What do you like?
-Pizza.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Would
you share it with me?
-Yes.
-If I had asked him,
what do you like to eat,
he would not give me
that same information.
That's a very simple question.
It was.
I don't get an answer, I
like pizza or a burger.
I have visuals at home usually.
I have them on the fridge.
And it's like, whoa, what do
you think you like to eat?
And he goes over there and
he'll pick the visuals.
-At home, he only do
requests, like I want this.
I want that.
It's very hard for him
to initiate conversation
to express himself.
-Thanks.
[HORN HONKS]
-Our buddy's saying, bye, house!
-Woody, the man!
-Bye house!
AUTOMATED VOICE:
It is kind of weird
that they say
good-bye to the house.
-OK.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Why do they do that?
-Because he is moving to the
truck and Woody's plan worked.
-Have you ever felt
afraid or ashamed
of being different
from other people?
-Sometimes.
-Maybe we can watch a clip
to understand how you feel.
-Sure thing.
-You belong down in Arendelle.
-So do you.
-No, Anna, I belong
here, alone, where
I can be who I am
without hurting anybody.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Have
you ever been afraid
and wanted to be alone?
-Sometimes.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Why?
-Because I have low
self-esteem and autism.
-Doing this, taking on this
other persona in order for her
to have a conversation, I could
more anonymously talk to her
or have her explain her
thoughts without it being mom.
-Right.
-Which speaks volumes.
-Amazing to get
him to this point
where he's actually
interacting with the devices.
But I think the ease
of use comes out
of the use of characters.
The voice also helps.
The visual helps.
-We go to therapists
a lot because
in the different environment,
he behaves very differently.
That's why I think
it's good that you
can do it at the therapist
and then do it at hoe.
Try to generalize
the skill he learned
and then practice at home.
That's why I think
it's a very useful app.
I think this is a very good.
-There's a therapist that
works with her that she sees
outside, just a personal one.
And I think something like this
would probably be a great thing
to sell to that field.
-It's that great?
-But I would have used
this as a tool with him
maybe to get him to express
his feelings of grief
around his father because it's
always a very difficult topic.
And with the use
of the character,
it would have been much easier
to get him to talk about it.
WOMAN: What's some other
stuff, in your own words,
about what it's like
to use Sidekick?
-So that way I don't can speak
to her when I'm in distress.
So that way, I can talk to her.
And she-- and she
understands how I feel.
WOMAN: Can you think of
anything that we could change
or add to make Sidekick better?
-You could add my
favorite movies
like "Inside Out"
and "Cinderella,"
and "Paul Blart, Mall Cop"
and "Home" and "Pixels."
-You think it was OK?
Or did you like it a lot?
-I liked it a lot.
-OK.
Awesome.
-Anything else you want
to share with us or ideas?
-When can we get it?
[LAUGHTER]
-Do you have any other
feedback for us about Sidekick?
-Oh, it was really great.
RON SUSKIND: Yeah,
it's cool stuff.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
So this is this brave new world.
We're releasing it in
the next month or so.
We have 100 folks who have
taken it home now in the pilot.
And it's amazing.
The heavyset kid whose dad died,
so he talks to the Sidekick.
And what's interesting
is that some of them
know that the parent's
behind the curtain.
They don't care.
Actually, no one cares.
Even neurotypicals don't care.
It's symbolic speech.
It's shadows on the cave wall.
It's the way we communicate
through shared context
just like in the movie theater.
And so he was talking
to the Sidekick.
The mom's in the bedroom.
He's in the den.
And he says, do you
have a family, to Griff,
the Sidekick, the avatar.
And the mom's like-- [GASPS].
And she types no.
And he's like, do
you have a father?
And she said no.
He's like, I don't either.
But I know how to be.
And I'm going to be OK.
And I can help you.
And then the mom, of course,
is bawling her eyes out.
And he runs up to the bedroom.
And he says, my Sidekick
doesn't have a dad either.
But I'm going to help him.
That's like Mozart.
That's an orchestra playing.
And the thing that I love
about "Paul Blart, Mall Cop"--
which is, you know-- is that
that's actually something that
echoes with us a lot and I think
a lot of families is that when
I say the ASD folks are
just brilliant consumers
and appreciators
of film, of music.
I mean, they're all running
their own music and film
appreciation classes in a
way because they have to be.
They've got to draw more
from it because they're not
drawing from this like we do.
And so there's a scene
where the girl, Kaitlin, is
telling the mom, here's
what I need you to feed it.
I know what I'm using.
So there was a moment in the
book where that happened where
Jonathan Freeman,
the voice of Jafar,
came to our house to visit
because we became buddies.
And he comes down for breakfast.
And Owen is playing
"A Whole New World."
And Jonathon's like, Owen,
are who playing that for me?
And Owen's like, no, I play
that every morning to get ready
for my day, which is
exactly what he does.
He's already got hundreds of
clips and passages of music
that he's using just like
Temple Grandin uses her squeeze
machine, to integrate,
to organize, to inspire,
to ground, for all the
things that we instinctively
do or maybe don't do.
And that's what's neat about it
is that it's very interactive.
And more and more, the
kids take control of it.
And because it's mobile
and it grows automation,
it's their support as
they go into the world.
I mean, I'm a content guy.
I've been doing
concert my whole life.
It's so exciting to think
about content living
more fully and deeply
in people's lives
where they actually live.
I mean, that's the dream, for
all available knowledge that's
now sitting on a PDA.
And these kids, I think, are
going to lead that charge.
That's the most
exciting part about it.
Look, we all talk about
big data and automation.
You know, it's not there yet.
Because the exchanges
are so rich and so
specific to the individual that
the data grows into automation
more forcefully-- look, we
can still plug in the API
as to whatever Cortana or Siri's
doing on movie times and pizza
toppings.
That's fine.
But in terms of something
that tailors itself
to who you actually
are, that's what
this does for this population
that really needs it.
a that's where we're going
right at at-need populations,
a lot of them, autism
first, but ADHD, OCD, PTSD.
I mean, someone from
the UN called and said,
how about refugee populations?
They've all got
Androids, all those kids.
So we're going to get a
gathering of specialists
in trauma and we're
going to build something
that sits on your platform that
they can talk to and grow with.
That's the crazy thing that's
going on with Sidekicks.
I've been yakking too much here
Can we get a couple questions?
s still have five
minutes at least.
AUDIENCE: And
actually, a question
related to that
because both of you
may have interesting
perspectives to share,
but I'm really
curious what companies
can do for employees
because I know
this is specific to our
world, and I'm in POps.
But I have the
experience that I have
a feeling there are
a lot of folks here
who would benefit from
an environment that's
more receptive to
their special talents.
So what can we do as a company?
I'm really curious.
RON SUSKIND: It's
a time of change.
People are seeing
that differently abled
is not just a PC term.
It's a term that's actually
more reflective of what is true.
So I think part of it is, again,
changing the wider populations,
whether in the workplace or
beyond it, to say, OK, well,
this is just a wide gap
of deficits and strengths.
I'm 50-50.
Owen's 30-70.
So it means that you've got to
place both the 30 and the 70
in your model, to say, yeah, I
know we support him on the 30.
Oh, yeah, that's hard.
He needs to take breaks.
And he needs the
lighting changed.
He's got to work at home some.
But I think the key
to that and the way
human beings are and the way
enlightened self-interest
works-- and that's the only
thing that really makes
the world turn, for
better or for worse--
is to prize the 70 as it is.
A friend of mine at
Harvard-- I teach
a class called Public
Narrative and Justice
at Harvard Law School.
And I have a lot
of buddies there
and this guy,
Howard Gardner, who
is the multiple intelligences
guy, so I've known for years.
He's an amazing guy.
At one point, I'm
like, Howard, it
would've been great if
we'd built yardsticks
for the other seven, eight
kinds of intelligences
other than just analytical,
cognitive, which is the winning
yardstick for everything.
He's like, yeah,
that would be great.
It's hard to do first.
But maybe now, we
can start doing
that because Owen does
certain things four
and five times better than me.
He should be measured on that.
And me too.
And I teach at
Harvard Law School.
OK?
He should get credit for
being a four x of me.
That's how we start to
see them as they all are,
prize them in the workplace,
support them as part
of a larger corporate purpose.
I mean, just a
little funny story
that says it so powerfully.
So I gave a speech at this
brain conference in Tel Aviv.
And it was a great.
Shimon Peres was there.
It was really exciting.
And so I talk about all this.
And a guy walks up to me
from Israeli intelligence.
Now, I wrote a book in 2006,
one of those big door stops
called "The One Percent
Doctrine" about the war
on terror.
And say his name's Avi.
OK.
And I'm like Avi, how
are you? [ISRAELI ACCENT]
Hey, Ron, it's nice to see you.
I heard you were
coming to Tel Aviv.
I said, yeah, yeah.
We loved the last book.
I said, you mean "The One
Percent Doctrine" on terrorism.
No, no, the one about your son.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, we have a division
at Israeli intelligence, 2,000
autistic spectrum young adults.
They see patterns in
the data we cannot see.
They're our secret weapon.
They keep Israel safe!
I go, oh, my god!
And I'm like, so they
want to watch movies, let
them watch movies.
And I love that
story because it's
someone under
duress, the Israelis,
seeing things with clarity,
as the Israelis will.
And that feels like
the future to me.
Once you start
seeing it that way,
you say, I want 10 of them, 20.
And what's the
special skill here?
Oh, this is-- can
we measure that?
Oh, that's fabulous.
The other part of
it though, it's
not even the big muscle in
terms of some of that heightened
ability.
It's also the social supports.
And I'll tell you--
and every parent-- I
know Eileen feels this way.
And certainly Paulette
knows this in her life--
is that when there's a person
who's different, whether it's
a spectrum person
or any person who's
neurodiverse among
neurotypicals,
they make us all better.
They just do because they
call the same question
that Owen called in our family.
I mean, I could go
survey 20 businesses.
How's the workplace atmosphere?
How do they treat employees?
How do they treat customers?
And then I could plant
a spectrum person
in each business,
re-survey them.
Everything will improve.
They'll treat each other
better in the workplace.
They'll treat customers
better when they come in.
Customers will come
to see the person.
It's their favorite employee.
That's complex, hard to
measure, but absolutely true.
So the question is,
how do we get there?
And I think
everyone's getting it.
And we're just a part
of it, all of us here.
And if it's going to happen,
it's going to happen here.
You know that.
This is Google, for Christ sake.
You guys are grasping
the reins of the future
in terms of especially data.
I'm a journalist.
We had no data forever.
I never even knew
who read the stories
I wrote in the "Journal."
You've got data which reveals
us as to who we really are.
It's going to happen at a place
like this, here or Facebook
or Microsoft or one
of the big shops
because people say OK,
we have the horsepower
and by virtue of the fact
that we are embracing
neurodiverse people
who are stars
and are valued members of
our teams, we're changing.
And we're seeing it.
And now we know what to do.
SPEAKER: So on that
powerful note, Ron,
thank you for the
storytelling, the inspiration,
for the book and the movie.
[APPLAUSE]